Hey guys, it's Joel with the Tabaret Therapy Collective podcast. And I haven't done like a big article, essay, podcast in a minute. We've done a lot of interviews and things. And I also get some feedback from people because I get really excited about an idea. I'm kind of obsessive. Like I get on a thing and then I try and like learn a ton about it. And then I want to talk to somebody else who's like really smart about that thing. And I try and line up guests that have, uh, you know, something to do with, uh, you know, something that I hope is relevant to you and psychotherapy
and culture and politics and all that, but also, um, something that I'm obsessing over and, um, have been learning a lot about. And then when I get on the interview with the guests, a lot of the feedback that I've gotten, it's like, hey, shut up, you're interrupting the guest. And maybe one way that I can be better about having more of a conversation and not, you know, interrupting, you know, I'm interrupting too much. That's not a good thing, is to sit with some of these ideas. And in sitting with some of those ideas in an essay thing with just me, you know, you just got to listen to me, it's easier to go into an interview. So anyway, something I'm trying out. And recently, this has to do with the topic today.
I was reading Michael S. Judge's book, which is Lyrics of the Crossing. It's a really good novel. And the thing in the beginning of it, there's a section in the beginning that I think is relevant to what we're talking about today. So I'm going to read that. The watcher's eyes now give out light. The light's receiver flower, coiled up behind their nose bones, changes place. It crawls out through their pupils, the bundled nervy flowers making a circuit between each other. Bolts the color of limes Boil forking through the busy air Their brains are still inside them
But the sundown is made to simmer With a brain that none of them quite have alone And each one has something like it Facets of the brain's shelled diamond The cage-strumming man Str strings out his carousel of shapes, while catgut thrums out slippery chords, and the people watching him are in the circuit of an ancient battery that sleeps behind their eyes, and none of them will know how to tell what has happened,
but everyone will know that it can happen again. And they'll say, I was a tree. I was a vine that sucked the brass work. I was an ivy knot that lived on the milk of stones. So that's from Michael S. Judge's Lyrics of the Crossing, which I'm not very far into. And it's a description which has a whole lot going on, you know, probably talk about that for an hour. But also it's a description that is of a bard, you know, like a performer singing a song, doing some kind of performance. And in the section before that, he talks about the catgut cage because, you know, the strings of old tennis rackets the strings of old instruments were made with cat gut but he describes the lyre or whatever this guy is playing like it is a cage he calls it a cage stringed with cat gut but it's an instrument
and if you think about um you know classical mythology who plays the lyre? It's Orpheus, right? And the lyre makes such beautiful music that he can call a soul out of the underworld, except for the one he wants. He has this beautiful lyre. But here, Judge is calling it a cage that is trapping something. And there's something going on there about the music basically pulling these people's brains outside of their eye holes because the sunset, like the setting that they're in, or the time that they're in maybe, we don't know if it's a sunset on a beach or the sunset that
he's describing of an epoch changing of culture, connects all of their brains, right? Like what a wild description. The lights receiver flower coiled up behind their nose bones. That's your brain. It's the receiver flower coiled up behind your nose bone that receives the light, right? The cage, the instrument, the culture, the music pulls these people's brains either because of the time that they're in or the place that they're in something about this setting and he calls the brain he says faucets of the brain shall dime and they're only like a piece of a whole thing when they're pulled out and connected that connection and there's a battery language there's a circuit language it's an electricity becomes something that is bigger than them and also alive, right? So it's this connection that makes something bigger than all of these people alive in a way that they're a part of it and they know it, but they also don't know it. And there's just
so much there. Um, and I, I, if that doesn't make sense, that's fine. I think a lot of those themes are going to be relevant to what we're getting into. You know, the sundown has made the sundowns made to simmer with a brain that none of them quite have alone. You know, we are building a circuit by connecting people with a culture that is also a cage. And it is making them something that is not them by connecting them, right? And this is, this book is like 900 pages. Like, I don't know how I'm ever going to read it. This is on page 14, okay? The whole novel is written like this.
It's not a book of poetry. I can't really tell you. I mean, I would already recommend it, but I can't really say much more about how to recommend it to you because I haven't gotten beyond, you know, I think I'm on page 50 or something of this giant book. So I'm going to get into what I'm talking about today, which is the era that we're in is characterized by this hyper-rationality that if you can't see it, taste it, touch it, it's not real. And a lot of that comes from science and this pursuit of objective truth, production, accomplishment, consumption. And the human psyche that you see culturally, it finds itself just adrift in all of these pieces of culture and images that aren't really functioning like
culture and image used to mean. I mean, they're disconnected from these previous myths that used to give us purpose. Like they're the same symbol that's reminding them of something, but it's something that we don't quite believe anymore. And there's a lot of things that are traditional or hierarchical that seem hollow or erroneous. I see that coming up all the time in therapy now. And I see patients every day that describe this phenomenon, and they don't use those words, but it's as if they are saying, I don't know who I am anymore, but I don't know who i am anymore but i don't know who i am anymore not because i changed because all these nodes and reference points that i used to have in a culture to contextualize my identity have been stripped away and they've been made foreign
and they've been incomprehensible i can't grab onto it anymore. But the world looks the same. I remember it. It didn't change, but it looks the same, despite the fact that it is making me feel alienated and terrified and upset. And so it's not the aesthetics of the world that are different. The aesthetics are the same, but the effect that it has on me is different. But I can't see that. I can only feel that. So what the hell is it? Why? I must be crazy, right? Because I'm looking at a world that looks the same, but none of these symbolic images are working in the way that they're supposed to work. And so because the world looks the same, we feel crazy. When really it's our feelings that are telling us that the world is crazy,
even though it looks the same. And, you know, like, what do we do as therapists or patients just looking to find a therapist that kind of gets this somewhat? You know, effective therapy in this modern world, it needs to go over, it needs to get over its insecurities of the therapist feeling or looking crazy, okay? You know, if we don't let ourselves as therapists admit to patients that we also feel this pain and that we also feel crazy from these same forces, then how can, if you can't acknowledge these, then how can therapy,
or if you're not even aware of it as a therapist, because you are feeling it, then how can therapy do anything but gaslight us more? You know, we see the news, and like I see the news when I'm in a dentist's office or i have i've been recently have been sick like six times which is why i'm been gone for so long but like i feel when i look at the news like i'm on drugs even though i'm sober it's just like what is happening on tv like and i and i don't mean that I disagree with what's happening. I mean, I largely do. I mean, like, it doesn't seem real. Okay. It's a bigger issue than I don't like it. It's that it
makes me feel like I don't understand what's happening. Like this is, it's surreal. And, you know, I know that the people on the TV don't believe what they're saying and they're kind of, but they, even they look like they're going through the motions of something that isn't real anymore you know all angles of this you know and i'm not a politician i'm not a god i'm a therapist and so i'm paralyzed against these forces too you know as my patients are i can't do anything about them all i can do is reckon with them and in reckoning with them um you know like i can tell the patient i don't know how to do that you know i don't know how to reckon with these things but they are real what you are feeling looks true you know i'm turning on the news and people are trying to get me to fight about these
culture war things and it's like i can't really afford american cheese as somebody who makes like a pretty good salary for my kids when they want to have a sandwich in the park like can we talk about that can we talk about roads can we talk about health care and we're so far beyond that where the things that we're talking about are so many levels of like pretending to be things that other people pretended in the 80s that even they didn't believe and it seems so alienating and confusing. So, you know, I didn't understand the line that James Hillman was really, he was a Jungian analyst I've talked about before, but Hillman was really fond of quoting Auden, W.H. Auden, the poet. And I never really understood his fondness for this line until recently. And I've come around to it, but it's, we are lived by forces that we pretend
to understand. You know, the real stuff of our lives is coming through us. And by the time we think we know why we did it, that's gone, right? It's, you know, this kind of rope of life is just being pulled through you, um, in this way that's kind of depersonalizing there. Um, there's a line that I wish I could remember from, Prophet, that book. I should have grabbed that book. I always try and grab a bunch of things I might need to get into when I start to freestyle and then I don't always remember everything that might pop into my head over the course of an hour. But, you know, Auden's line, that highlights like how the frameworks and philosophies that we resort to for certainty, when we want certainty,
when we want order, when we want to feel stabilizing, they're kind of delusional. Sometimes it's a helpful delusion or a necessary one, but they're not real. And this grand meaning-making system of religion and science and politics and all this stuff that we feel like is supposed to give us some kind of certainty is failing to and so this cultural dominance when we put these forces of empirical science and all these things on this pedestal and expect them to do this for us but they're not doing it anymore you know we are feeling all of this anxiety and we cling you know tenaciously to these conceptual concepts and these hyper-real simulations because the alternative would be admitting that there's ambiguity, there's contradiction, there's unfathomable doubt that we all are having. And that seems like it would be too destabilizing. So the iconosphere is an idea by a philosopher, Baudrillard.
And one of my friends did an art... Actually, I don't know if he finished it. He might listen to this. But anyway, he did a... I'm remembering the first time he told me about it, which is a story I'm not going to tell. But he told me about this idea when he was reading a lot of this philosophical school called the simulacra, which is something that is a copy, but it doesn't have an original.
It's sort of a copy that replaced the original, but the original also was never real. So you get this paradox there because a copy is supposed to be a copy. And so when you say, okay, it's a copy copy but then there isn't a thing that it copied you have all of this you know philosophical stuff you can dig into if you want to drink some um bordeaux and uh make undergraduates miserable in france and so like the the econosphere is this conceptual idea um that jean beaugard talks about which you know i'm not you know know, I'm not, you know, a philosopher, I'm not an expert in any of these things, but there's this idea that, um, the iconosphere is this place, this sphere where there's these images that circulate and they multiply and they create
this hyper reality that creates the real world. And that we're in this place where we're seeing all this stuff that is like real vivid, more than real. But at the same time, those were the images. They don't really represent anything anymore. Um, they're referring to this external reality that is outside of reality, but then the hyper reality of reality is telling you that this is all there is. And so there's this sort of gaslighting effect of that, um, where we feel like, you know, the world that we're in is self-referential, it's self-generating, and there's something outside of it, but also the world is telling you that there's nothing outside of the world you're in. And so some key ideas here, you know, the realm with the simulacra, those copies and those simulations have replaced the original
and the authentic thing. A lot of correlations with something like LI, uh, AI or LLMs, the large language models that's going on now where, you know, you can look at it and you may, your brain may think it's real for a second, but another part of your brain says, no, like, I don't, I feel something bad with some of these images or some of this writing where you're halfway through an article and then all of a sudden it doesn't work. Um, but you don't know why it didn't work, you know, because of the grammar's right. It's real, but something knows it's not real. Um, and so this world of appearances and surfaces, all depth and meaning are lost. You're cut off from a source that these things used to point to, but it's no longer there. And in this realm of fascination and seduction where these images, they captivate you and they manipulate you, but also they're not real.
But then you are real and their effect on you becomes reality, which is sort of what I think he's getting at. You know, again, not a philosopher, not into a lot of these schools. I understand their influence and their ideas. And when they're relevant to something, I don't, you know, I can't teach a class on this, but, you know, in this world of illusion and virtualness, you know, it's virtual reality, right? A lot of these people I think are anticipating and describing virtual reality before virtual reality exists through intuition. They're in touch with these ideas. And it doesn't mean that you can see the future, but you can sort of see what society is doing, like this direction that it's going in.
That even after you're dead or 100 years after you're dead, it's not going to stop because you see these balls rolling and you know where that leads. And that's how they come to these ideas i think um so the implications of this like iconosphere unraveling is there's the symbolic order and it's profoundly disorienting like it's upsetting and you're always bombarded by these images or you know spectacles you know i'm hearing a voice of another person I went to school with a long, long time ago. But it produces this crisis of meaning and this sort of like impenetrable distance from you and the thing that is close to you, that you're right next to. So all these paradoxes and tensions here. And so these signs and reputations, they become unhinged from anything that they used to be hinged to.
They used to point to something, but what they point to is something we don't remember anymore. Reality becomes a dead language where we can see the script and we can say, well, I think this comes from, you know, an early Semitic language. I think that this is, you know, maybe like a proto runic script because it looks sort of like modern, but we don't even know what it's trying to say. But it's all that we have to hold on to and you know when i so sitting with that remember in high school when you had to read t.s elliott's the wasteland you know and one of the first line is that you know only a heap of broken images right so you know this crisis of meaning um that is is so that a french philosopher is talking about well here's a British guy at the end of World War one who everybody did the thing that they thought that you had to do because it made life good you put on the uniform
you marched out you went and you did it glory and country and all of a sudden it's not working anymore the machine gun doesn't care how brave you are you know the trenches have destroyed this country. And so, so much of the wasteland, which I really like, I could talk about the wasteland for an hour. I do like the wasteland. Um, like I do like Elliot a lot there, there are all these things that you are like witnessing an image and then you're almost starting to have an emotional connection to it. A lot of times those images are upsetting. Like you don't like it, like the conversation about getting new teeth. And, you know, this person cheating on their husband, like you're, you're affected by it, but you're it's not good.
But then before you can even react to the badness of it, you're ripped away from it. The whole wasteland is like this shifting kaleidoscope. It's it's kind of an upsetting poem to read, but in a way that is really interesting because it is giving voice to this thing that I think we all feel, not through philosophy and kind of, you know, deconstructive, you know, postmodernism, but through poetry. And this heap of broken images that he's talking about in the very beginning, I think that's what he's telling you. He's like, I'm not going to even tell you this story. I'm just going to let you feel a little bit of what it's like and where we're going here.
And, you know, that theme is very similar to, you know, and if you want to jump back and listen to me talk about it, that mysticism versus objective, or not objectivism, the objective versus the mystical, that episode, I cover this, but Edward Edinger, you know, the post-Jungian, he's a Jungian analyst, and he says basically that there's an objective part of our brain that what we can taste, touch, and feel, which I'm going to say with more neurological, you know, science available to me than Edinger, that is the prefrontal cortex. That's a lot of these event-related potentials that are using the front of my brain and then there's a mystical base of the brain um mysticism that is yes trauma is stored there so a lot of those reactions are
like unpleasant and upsetting but also like my intuition you know maybe my soul if you want to get really mystical these things that don't fit into language, they don't fit into knowledge, but they're still real. How do I know that they're real? Because the person is back being like an enlightened atheist or a scientist being like, oh, you think your emotions are real? I know they're real because I can see every single person acting on all of this archetypal energy and I can read history and I can see that that never ended and that that probably never will. So yeah, they're real. Okay. Um, and these two parts
of the brain, the subjective, which is the emotional, um, uh, and the, um, you know, maybe it's sort of childish from one perspective, but it's also, if it's overindulged, but it also is like our intuition, which tells us like what our purpose is. And like, if we're happy and if something is just good, you know, like when I look at the direction culture is going with these large language models and these different things, I just know that it's bad. Like I know it's cutting,
not because I'm afraid of it, but because I feel like it's moving in the direction where we're putting more and more resources away from the things that make us human, like education and community and psychology and not connection with nature and a take your shoes off and go to a Dave Matthews concert, you know, the hippie way, but like connection with nature in a way that like we need it to live. And if we don't have a planet, we die, you know, big things like that. I can, yeah, make a logical argument for that, but I'm realizing, you know, the logical argument that I'm making is because I feel this intuitively first and that isn't coming from this logical place.
So Edinger says, you know, like these two things, the subjective and the objective, there are two parts of the brain. You know, one is glommed on as a newer addition, basically, through evolution. And they don't want to be in the same head. And so they tend to kind of fight and repress each other and you know a lot of what freud is trying to describe with the unconscious and imperfect language that i don't like and a lot of freud's biases built into that you know jung refines in a way that i think makes it a lot more universal and explains a lot more like history and mythology and culture and like early latent psychology a lot better than Freud's model does, you know, like, you want to go back to the Venus of Willendorf and talk about like the id, like,
it just doesn't work in the way that Jung's model describes that. And so same thing here, right? You know, I don't want to lose the thread too much by qualifying Edinger, but you have the idea of the iconosphere you have the idea of the wasteland you know and there are you know from a jungian perspective at the core of our human experience there are these archetypal energies that are biological unconscious drives they defy reason but they are still part of us and that you so you know edinger is is going through that and he has a picture that he draws where he's like you know thank god for the catholic church or something well i mean he doesn't say this in the picture but he like he shows like here's a religious or political system that is functioning well and here's yourself and it has all these archetypes
that it's projecting out that they don't have to directly encounter the divine they don't have to directly um be in touch with this archetypal source because that community is telling you oh you want to be a helper go be a social worker your your church is saying you want to do something with the messianic energy here's jesus here's the messiah oh here's the good mother you know the virgin mary you know, the Virgin Mary, you know, like, you know, our culture and our democracy does that too. You don't have to be religious, you don't have to be Catholic, but you're being told, like, you don't have to go out and figure out what to do with these from the beginning of reality. Like, you're a caveman, there's a whole cultural construct that teaches you to hold these archetypes so when you have and it can be a secular deity but you know he even says on his diagram i think um i'll try and look up where i
took a picture of the book a long time ago because the book has long been lost but um that's one of those books i think i've bought like five times that and dominion of the dead is another one that robert poke Harrison like there's some books that i i think i i would i probably spent more than like three hundred dollars buying paperback copies of some books. But like the secular deity could be capitalism, like it could be communism. And when it breaks down, and he quotes in this diagram, he quotes Eliot. He doesn't say that, but I guess he thinks that you would be familiar with it. But he says there's this heap of broken images where all of a sudden there's nothing containing these forces.
Like I'm just going out and I'm feeling something and I'm having to figure out what to do with it. Even if I figure out a couple of them, I'm not going to figure out all of them right. And if society and our religious and political systems are in crisis, all of that energy just hits you and you can't figure out what to do with it. And you start acting on intuition in a way that is unconscious and that is bad. And what that looks like is neurosis and psychosis um it can look a lot like schizophrenia you look at some of the conspiracy theories here and i'm not telling you which one to believe or not to believe but if you look at them you can look at the same people and it's like the next day they're like well the 5g is going through the aliens and whatever and you're like wait a minute i thought you said that there was a secret pedophile cabal and that like this person did
yeah yeah that too but no no there's a new it's like no but that isn't consistent like you're saying a different thing every day and these things don't fit together well it's because it's archetypal it's not logical you know right like there the system has broken to where we're feeling all of this stuff we're looking at this world where it is failing to contain um reason essentially like it's not making We're looking at it, and the people who are saying these things don't even look like they believe it anymore. They don't even look like they're trying to. And that creates this dissonance of like, well, this world must not be real, so what is real is this thing that I can feel. And there is a danger to that. And again, this isn't a new thing. You know, like I talked in our cults and conspiracy theories a lot series about how like when these systems break down
historically, people do start to say they believe in magic. They start to, because you know, when people are in crisis, they gravitate towards a magical system. They gravitate towards making meaning that way. And, you know, so Edinger is another, and what I'm trying to do is throw a bunch of people at you that are saying the same thing, I think, from a different perspective, intuitively, with very different language. Because I think that when you go into these places intuitively and you confront these things honestly, and you don't discard science and just call yourself a wizard, it's fine to do that. But if you don't do that and you try and understand the role that science can play, but you don't limit yourself by the role science can play, you also are in touch with this kind of archetypal and inherently subjective part of the brain that you just can't objectify it. You can't
turn it into a screener, you know? Like we can't turn everything that we're going to work with in therapy into something that we can assess with a number. We just can't. Um, when you, when you sit with both of them, you end up saying this, something like the iconosphere, like the wasteland, like ego and archetype, the Edward Nettinger book, you say something kind of like the lens that Nietzsche uses. You know, Nietzsche sees logic as a form of insecurity, which is really interesting to me, because it's true. Like, when he's writing, what he's saying is he's looking for these people who are very logical empirical either philosophers or scientists that are looking for these like very rational examinations of truth they think there's an
absolute truth that they can find if they can just spin their intellectual gears you know wheels enough and and that he sees that as this confession that those people are terrified and anxious and looking for a certainty that is not real it was like um that you would build this monument to your intellect and your ego only when you are so afraid that you're gonna die and not matter and be unimportant and that no one would do that if they don't think that way right like if you have a whole society build you a pyramid a giant pyramid you're kind of afraid of dying, right? Because that pyramid is telling on you, hey, the Pharaoh thinks that they're going to not live. And so they've made this whole thing of if I make this insane tomb with all these traps
and my body stays there, the Ba and the Ka will come out and it'll go visit my relatives. Basically, everything that I want to do, you know, I have to make it hard and that makes it real. Right. And then I have to involve the culture in it and that's going to make it real. You know, that's the Pharaoh doesn't want to die. Okay. You know, the pyramids are a great example of something that serves like no practical strategic military, even political purpose. Like everyone resented the pyramids. They were a big point of contention it's only a psychological thing for the leadership you know to have that and so there there's like so much truth in what nietzsche's doing when he he says that you know science and philosophy um obsession with science and philosophy
with the logical nature of those things the empirical nature of those things he's not against them but when there's this obsession with the empirical and objective parts of them taken to an extreme, it's an unconsciously projected psychological struggle. And that you can use that to analyze, psychoanalyze, you know, the author of these works. And there's so much truth in that. Like when I had a patient come in one time, I've actually had a couple of people come in, um, cause they see existential, there's a joke. Okay. There's a joke that like we make it consultation groups sometimes that like when a patient sees existential therapy on your bio and they come in because they want to talk to an existentialist, the last thing that they actually need is existentialism. Um, I've had multiple patients that have come in and
have quoted that, um, Oh, what's his name? I don't remember that have come in and have quoted that um oh what's his name I don't remember that anyway they've quoted the French play where they say you know that hell is other people and when they say that I know this that isn't relevant like what other people do or what you're how other people like the point what you're telling me is that I feel like I'm in hell and so that's where I start, you know, as a therapist. And so, you know, Nietzsche's arguing that these more philosophical work, they present, you know, the people that present this stuff as just pure logical analysis, that's going to get to this truth. That's kind of this grandiose insane claim that lets you know
that they're crazy. Um, or, you know, crazy. That's, I don't, I don't mean to be, um, too hard on some of the people that Nietzsche talks about, but like they're cut off from this other part of themselves that they don't want to be real in a way. Right. He's saying the same thing that Edinger says. I don't think if you got these guys at a table that they would all agree and be like, Oh yeah, we all figured out the same thing. I don't think that at all. That's not what I'm saying. I'm saying that they're responding to solving the same tension and in a way that is unique to them, which is really what we as therapists and patients, as we move into this modern realm, like that's kind of what we all should be doing and teaching our patients to do. Like if there's a future for therapy,
if you want to find a point to this article or this essay, it's well, this list of notes that I'm reading, then I'll probably, um, you know, try to get, you know, an LLM to transcribe what I'm done talking is and put it on the blog is like that. We have to make patients with these tensions and figure out their own language and their own way to do this. If there's a future for therapy, it's that, you know, amidst all of this broken images, it's not more logic. Um, it isn't more of the things that are failing and it isn't pretending that those things aren't failing. That's the worst thing that we can do. Um, it's in the same way that you can feel right? You can find your model for therapy. You
can find your model for being a person in life, you know, to heal yourself through Nietzsche, Edinger, you know, the idea of the iconosphere, a poem like The Wasteland, a million other examples if I had, you know, another day, you know, to think about the stuff I would come up with, or kind of reconciling the same tension. And you can see that these people don't agree. They're not doing it the same way, but they kind of are, right? And that's the paradox, if you want to look for a point of this. So, I mean, instead of trying to, like, impose these pre-existing frameworks of meaning onto a patient's existence, they come to me meaningless, and then I give them a framework for making
meaning. I think we have to make them make their own meaning, which is harder therapy to do. It's hard to teach because the therapist has to sit with their uncertainty too, to teach the patient to do it. That's why I'm not telling you how to do this. I'm not saying how I do it. You know, I'm saying, I'm trying to get you to feel it, you know, when I, when I write something like this. So like, you know, by learning to let go of this need for certainty and control and cultivate the sense of openness and creativity in the face of the unknown, you know, the patient can begin to discover themselves in a more authentic and empowering way. But there's long dark nights of the soul here.
It's hard, right? You know, what's the Simone Bay quote about that? When the patient is in the labyrinth, we or not the patient, but the person is in the labyrinth, you're walking on this dark track and you don't even know if you're going in a circle. It feels like that, that knowing that you have to keep walking, even if you may just be walking in a circle until you starve and die is part of the process that you have to face in order to heal. That you have to keep going, even knowing that you going somewhere may mean that you have to face in order to heal. That you have to keep going, even knowing that you going somewhere may mean that you're not going anywhere. That you have to go through that.
You know, and what is it, Fritz Perls? I got my Perls here. So the Gestalt therapy guy said, you know, the aim of therapy was to help the patient come to this point where they could live with uncertainty without props. I think he says without props. Which is a funny word. That almost is perfectly referring back to something like the iconosphere.
That there's this feeling that we have to conform in order to belong. And that we have to get these things that are the symptoms of a healthy life or a happy life but we don't actually have to confront our insecurity and know what that is he says that the person has to learn you know to live by their own resources which means not the therapist resources you can't tell them how to do it and so walter benjamin is another one who, again, I'm not an expert on this, but he's reflecting on a lot of these same ideas. And he's talking about the shock experience, that we live in this culture that is constantly causing us shocks and wearing us down to nothing because this need to have constant consumption for economy under capitalism means that there has to be constant production which means that the things have to age because there has to be a new thing you know and he's writing really at the beginning of the
age of what would turn into a culture driven by mass production. I mean, he sees mass production, definitely, but not its effect on culture. Like now, you know, think of the news cycle as different in 12 hours. Like you sound like you're, if you're like, hey, remember the thing that was a scandal like two months ago? No one even knows what you mean.
You know, something like when I was a kid, the Clinton scandal, like it was like two years of like the same thing. And now like, it was like two years of the same thing. And now you don't even remember what the last thing was. Well, products do that, computer, everything has to be replaced. And that those perpetual shocks, what Benjamin is saying there, is that there's this ubiquitous experience that is kind of traumatic and is always happening.
And so we don't even feel it anymore. Like we become numb to it. And that those protective barriers that used to be ritual and tradition and collective meaning are eroded by you just having to participate in this litany of consumption and production in order to participate in culture at all. And that leaves us incredibly vulnerable. And it also makes it very hard for us to know why we're doing something, because everything that we're doing is something we have to do, not something that we want to do or something that we choose. I was thinking about that today when I wanted to like hang out with my friends and I
took my son for a walk. And it's like one of the first times I haven't been sick for like a month and a half and just the first minute that I had and I called my friend and I was talking to him and I was realizing my neighbor up the hill had said like hey why don't we hang out and I was like in my head I was like look I don't even get to hang out with the people who I know like all I do is like work at Taproot and then see my kids if I have any time off like yeah you seem like a nice person but like I don't even get to hang out with my closest friends like when am I gonna walk up the street and do whatever when then I was kind of repulsed by that internally and was like why can't I have a community and go hang out with my neighbor he seemed like a nice guy but I'm realizing that like
and my patients were saying the same thing about like they were lonely and wanted to do this but everything that we do is something we have to do because everything is tied to this notion of production and consumption in this way that has accelerated culture so much that we really don't have that much free time and we really don't have that much choice you know like i wouldn't run a therapy collective probably if i was a millionaire and didn't have to work I just wouldn't I would do something else I would go hang out with my neighbor up the hill um but I think that that speed of culture is sort of what he's getting at there that there's these you know insights that everything I mean and I get more of like a felt texture from what I've read I'm not not at all an expert on him but it does seem like more of this kind of felt experience of
just being worn ragged by the pace of everything and giving, and that being something that's hard to do. So I'm going to try and wrap this up. Um, but that we're always in the same way that, you know, capitalism is making you produce and consume these things, um, you know, just content to have, to sell, to whatever. That's also kind of applied to culture. Like we have these inner images, we have these outer images and we're constantly like manufacturing and replacing those things. Um, and like we can start to be more aware of our inner world and we can start to understand
what we've internalized. I'm trying to take something from him that I can turn back into a therapy point. And some of these images that were internalized that we have to have, my life has to be this, it has to do that or culture, whatever. I mean, that may be from a value system that's 30 years old now, or, or just not mine. You know, like look at these images that are internalized because we also project and react to those externally, you know, and, um, and make a choice. The things that you have inside of you, that's, that's an option. You know, there's, I'm not want to give like two practical language for this, um, or, or two, like, I'm not trying to make a new model of therapy here. I'm trying to point to how therapy has to change if it's going to be relevant. And some of it is just sitting with like, Hey, what did you absorb from the world? Like, is that a good thing?
Do you want that in you? Are you participating in that thing? You know, externally, just because you have this inward image that you can discard? Or are you letting something that you think is like not real in the world, this thing from, you know, that basically is, you know, a symbol or a reality that used to be something relevant that you don't even care about and form your inner world, maybe you should have more of a filter or a barrier to that, you know, talking about these kinds of cultural forces i think is important um and so uh i know i had talked about adam carter's a couple times but the the movie that i refer to a lot because i don't think that all of his are great um i think
that they work more i won't get into that i think the ones that are kind of metaphorical work more than the ones that are literal but um like the all-watched-over-by-machines-of-loving-grace film that Adam Curtis did that's like a documentary that's kind of deconstructing some of these cultural forces. I really like that one. But the name of it is based on – because I think if you want to pull like a point from that movie, it, cause it, it sort of defies a point. Like none of Adam Curtis's movies are ever like, we set out to prove this, but what we actually found scared us even more.
And what is, there's no thesis. Like it's this very felt sort of art film thing, but if you want to pull a thesis out of all watched over by machines of loving grace, like I think what he's saying is that when we started to make a culture and it got way worse way faster when we uh invented computers because it entered our you know i guess the iconosphere like it entered the way that we thought about the world which changed the way that we thought about ourselves but when we started to conceive of people like
computers that could be programmed that were just machines, that if we made the perfect circumstance to control them, that their behavior would be a hundred percent predictable, that you could design a culture. Like that's when things went south because we're not computers. Like we don't fit into a binary, you know, because like computers don't dream, you know, like computers we we are driven mad when we can't dream because we're humans and computers think in binary like they are machines for processing information um and if you want to say like oh maybe chat gpt5 is going to be sent here or something no it won't because so much of like what i've tried to say with these articles with like our line of thinking and looking at psychology in the weird
way that we look at it on on this podcast is that our humanity kind of comes from the tension between two things that don't want to be in the same head and so much of our anxiety and so much of our vibrancy and our beauty as humans but also like our madness is trying to solve this paradox of these two things that don't go together that are a paradox they are mutually exclusive like they do annihilate yet they can't because they are part of the same thing right a large language model is essentially a just predictive engine it's just saying this word was connected to these words with this probability in this way. How much money do you want me to spend crunching the numbers in the
CPU on a server to predict how likely it is that the word is going to go next to this one? And you can get a really good equivalency of language if you spend a lot of money and your burn rate is really high on your company that's designing this llm ai thing and you can get a very poor approximation of language that is writing in comparative sa you know fifth grader voice if you don't spend very much that's it that can't become sentient because it is a spreadsheet it is a very complicated spreadsheet it is not there is no philosophical tension that makes us human um which is what i would call you know our humanity um so to wrap this up you know that that poem that all watch over by machines of loving grace is named after which is all watch over by machines loving grace a poet richard brodigan is i think an electrical engineer some kind of engineer in the 70s so this is like so
70s i'm not gonna read the whole thing um i'll put it on the blog post of this when i when i get it written probably by an llm um after i transcribe it but it was like about uh you know so yeah okay so i got the point uh here's here's the beginning of it i like to think and the sooner the better of a cybernetic meadow where mammals and computers live together and mutuality and programming harmony like pure water touching clear sky i like to think right now please of a cybernetic forest filled with pines and electronics where deers stroll peacefully past computers as if they were flowers spinning with blossoms okay so the poetry sucks it's not a very good poet um but the idea
here that is interesting is this person just thinks that like basically machines and nature you know like computers and nature are inherently the same thing and one day we'll sort of like synthesize into the same thing right the end of mass effect one if you play video games or i guess three spoiler alert um like the that is so nuts that i think curtis takes it and one of the things that this guy did that he goes on about in the um he goes on about in the documentary is that he was trying to make a circuit diagram of all of nature because he thought you could reduce all of nature to these completely empirical objective things and so he was trying to draw like a little thing of like oh you know
the deer eats the grass and so that's like plus five amperage of energy that goes into the battery of the deer's leg but it has to go through the resistor of the deer's uh digestive system and point you know 1.5 of the amps are turned into poop or whatever i don't know like he's trying to play dnd with a meadow and turn everything into you know an, an attribute. And that is wild. That's just real wild. So that kind of thinking, I think, is dangerous. And that's why I mentioned that in here. So, you know, these days of psychoanalysis, which psychoanalysis basically starts the same way. Freud says, like, we can take every single part of the person apart, we can label it, we can teach them what it is. And then when they put it all back together,
um, the, it'll work because they don't know how the engine of their car works. And it's just like, I taught my 15 year old how to, I don't have a 15 year old, but I'm just, and Freud didn't either, but well, I guess he did at one point, but he didn't teach her how to drive it civic. So like, it's like the person being like, yeah, I taught my 15 year old how to drive the civic. She knows how to check the oil. She knows how to do this. She knows how to take it apart if it breaks, whatever. For we thought we could do that with a brain in the same way that Richard Brodigan thought that we could do that with nature in the same way that Adam Curtis is criticizing, you know, that, like, you were just building this engine. But that doesn't work, you know. And if you look at a lot of the post
Jungian writers, especially David Tacey, who I really like, I think he's like one of the most nuanced and honest about dealing with Jung as a person and his like real, you know, um, he doesn't project on Jung at all, um, in a way that a lot of analysts do. Um, but Tacey talks about this idea of the post-secular sacred. That's a really good book that Tacey wrote, if you want to read a David Tacey book. But he has this idea that in the beginning of time, we believed in magic because we had to.
We were evolving. We needed to believe that we had control over the sun and the moon, and we just saw these psychic pillars of humanity, and we asked them over the sun and the moon and we just saw these psychic pillars of humanity and we asked them to help us and feed us and like whatever and um we projected our own psychology onto a world that was dead and um and that made it alive like us it made a part of us and that kept us healthy and that was this first kind of epoch of myth and then science comes along and they say like, no, no, no, that's actually irrational and crazy. Like, don't do that. What you can do is just label like every
single thing and then understand what it is. And then you can just become, you can build anything you want through objectivism. You don't have to deal with magic. You don't have to deal with subjectivity. You don't have to deal with uncertainty. Maybe we haven't figured it out yet, but we will figure it out and you'll know everything. And so instead of like begging God to help you, it basically science would, you know, empower us to feel like we are the gods, which is, I would argue, a worldview that is failing. Because I don't know about you, but I don't feel like God. I think younger people feel worse. They feel like they have less certainty, yet we have this hyper real, ultra logical,
ultra production focused, ultra consumption focused, scientific empirical reality that is telling us that we feel good, but we know we don't. And the thing is, that's how I know that these are not logical realities, that Nietzsche is right, is because we don't feel good, right? So you can do the math problem and say it proves that this, I should feel fine. And the culture is saying I should feel fine. And I have all the images and the stuff around me of a healthy life. I have all the symptoms of being happy. But guess what? You don't. Okay. And that voice that says you're not is real. And the first step in getting back in touch with this stuff is admitting that it is real, even though you can't see it and touch it and taste it and
sort of re-achieving balance between these things. So, you know, like what does that kind of therapy look like? Again, I'm not making a new model of therapy um but this could like lead us to understand inner wisdom and and compassion and the stuff that i talk about all the time instead of driving trying to just strive to perfectly understand and control and so you know patients could start to understand like how to embrace the uncertainty of life um and and that being a good thing or an inevitable thing a thing that maybe makes us terrified but also motivates us um i had a cbt therapist which a lot of cbt therapists are great therapists even though i don't like cognitive therapy if you code a lot of cbt therapists they've just done it long enough that they
may say they do cbt they're not really doing CBT anymore. I had a CBT therapist and he said, turn your fear into anxiety. Or no, I'm sorry. He said, turn your like fear and anxiety into motivation and excitement because it's the same energy. It just matters how you interact with that energy and what you're telling yourself about it. It's the same
emotion. I wasn't afraid. I was excited because I wanted to change. And I didn't know how I would, or if I could, but feeling it that way was so much better for my brain. And so because therapists, this is hard because we have to admit that we're adrift in this uncertainty and that these systems are failing that we don't know how to fix. And you're, you don't want to offend the patient's politics or you don't want to make them more depressed. Well, you know, they know this anyway, how much respect do you have for yourself and how much respect do you have for your patients? I mean, who, oh, well, like whenever I hear a therapist be like, oh, they're just not ready to hear the greater. I'm having to listen to her go on about this kind of narrative,
but she's just not ready yet to know. You don't respect this person. I used to see teenagers, and I still treated them with the respect that I would give an adult. Who do you think you are? You're maybe just not ready to have that conversation with them. I just don't get that kind of therapy at all. I'm there with you as a therapist. I think good therapists should be. I'm not like judging you and analyzing you and deciding, you know, when you're mature
enough to whatever, you know, and guess what? I mean, the therapist, you say that when is the patient ready? They aren't the therapist, the relationship falls apart in four years. And then they just say, oh, they weren't ready to go there or whatever. You know, like the therapists who say the patient's not ready, like I never see them get the patient ready. You know, as somebody who has talked to a lot of therapists for a long time and been in that world for a long time, and also talked to a lot of therapists who do kinds of therapy I don't do. So, you know, we have to be honest with patients. But in doing that, we run the risk of seeming stupid. We run the risk of seeing unqualified because, oh, I don't
know what to tell you. So this will end. So I guess I'm not good enough. You know, we run the risk of seeming crazy. If you have those insecurities, deal with them and then go into therapy, right? Like deal with those insecurities if you're a therapist, because you're not stupid, you're not unqualified and you're not crazy, but yeah, somebody may think you are, what does that do to you? You know, we don't know how to do this as therapists either. We can't pretend to, and we don't know how, but we have to develop the, I mean, maybe it's a post-secular faith or something, but we have to develop the, I mean, maybe it's a post-secular faith or something, but we have to develop an intuition to know which direction that we go in, even if we don't really
know how this ends or which direction to go. And we must do like all of this in a culture that has given us nothing but a heap of broken images and a whole mess ton of uncertainty for a long time. That's what it's done. And so for the postmodern self, you know, how does that fit into a world? We just, we can't rewind the clock. You know, the YouTube video where somebody makes an argument and they're like, oh, you know, we have all this woke culture or this corruption and this bad thing. We just need to go back and be the Roman empire. Like how the hell are you going to go back and be the Roman empire? Like I've never heard a single one of those people, other than they just don't like a group of people,
have any kind of idea how you make a world full of billions of people forget that the last thousand years happened. Or 500, or however far you want to go back. And then just say, remember, none of those cultural things are an option anymore. Could you just kind of forget that? That's wild. You can. Like, we are in post post-modernism. Um, that's where we are and we are lived by these forces that we pretend to understand, like Auden says. And, you know, these archaic currents that are coming through us of this archetypal life are perpetually destabilizing any kind of
rational narrative or personal identity that you try and make which can be terrifying or it can be exciting it's the same energy and yet these are not obstacles that should just be mastered you know they're i wouldn't put this on the treatment plant. They're this raw material of their creative thermals of wind that you can fly on. And now maybe you have to surf on sometimes. You know, therapy becomes this art of presencing the interplay of potentiality and metabolizing things. And if you want to go in an alchemical language, a Jungian way, and talk about alchemy,
that language works too. But this goal of psychotherapy in this post-secular, post-empirical world, where we realize the limitations of science, and we realize the limitations of mythology alone, or magic, believing in magic, whatever, we realize the limitations of mythology alone, or magic, believing in magic, you know, whatever, we realize the limitations of that, you know, like, it can't go after this absolute truth. Not just because Nietzsche will make fun of you, but it has to help patients develop this capacity
to face the unknown with courage and curiosity and compassion by embracing a more humble, intuitive approach to mental health. And we have to admit that we don't know. We have to admit uncertainty. We have to sit in uncertainty and we can help individuals find meaning in a world that is always going to be in change. Because if you're waiting for the environment to change, like it doesn't always, especially when that environment is culture, you know, uh, but we can cultivate resilience. Um, and if you're scratching your head and you're like, I don't know what to do that. I don't know how to do that. That's, that's fine. That's good. You're thinking about it. I don't know how to do it either, but I have faith and I feel that faith is more real than what I know.
And the future has always been a simulacra, right? The future has always been a copy without original because the past is built on all these copies of inner images that people were externalizing, sometimes consciously and sometimes not. And all we can learn is to recognize these images inside ourselves and these images outside ourselves and the interplay between those how we're taking them in how we're taking them out and make a choice make it a choice instead of an unconscious process and you know our lives are always this interplay of forces that we cannot we can't prevent or defeat that but what we can do is learn to build behavior and and cultural machinery to handle the dynamics of the flow of those forges forces i don't know if anyone's seen
patriot on amazon it's good but i think the book that like the his engineer boss writes is called like the the dynamics of flow or something um he's it's, it's, he's an engineer. Um, but like we, we are lived by forces that we pretend to understand, but we have to remember too, that they are lived through us. You know, we are lived through them and they are lived through us. There's an interplay that we, and we can have some awareness of that tension. Um, and that is scary because it makes us a little bit less of an individual. It makes us a little bit less of an individual. It makes us a little bit less of a monolith or this monadic thing that is going through life. But that isn't life.
You have archetypes within you. There are archetypes outside of you. We can look at how these things are knocking together. But that means that you have to let go of what you are right now or this thing that's completely in control because you're not you know when i was in psychotherapy i remembered that there were all these drowning and swimming metaphors in school too and like that you know just there's a ton of like well you got to learn to swim sometimes the backstroke whatever and you know you're trying to do the if you're floating on your back and the or you know like yeah that that protective part it was helping you out and it was a stick that kept you float in the river.
But now the stick is about to go over the waterfall. And if you can't let it go and swim to the shore, if you keep holding on to the protective part, you know, all of that stuff, but maybe the sea is just too rough right now to teach patients to swim like that has changed. And we can't do that. And we need to teach patients how to sail both. You know, Freud taking apart the whole engine and trying to teach the patient how to be a speedboat or fix the speedboat, not going to happen. The sea is too rough to swim. But we can teach them to be in conversation with these forces
in a way that is sustainable, like through sailing. And maybe we can build a culture that can learn to, like, sail and cruise ships again. You know, um, maybe we can be in conversation with the storm, um, because it's not going to go away. And if it does, it's not going to go away because of magic, because of anything we did. And it's not going to go away because of science. We are in a storm, and I think that instead of trying to swim, we need to remember to breathe, and we need to remember how to use the wind. Thank you. Продолжение следует... There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.